first Americans are hunkering down this
morning as a pandemic brings us our
personal and moral work lives rather to
a complete standstill it is very scary
President Trump has made it clear this
is no time to take any chances my
administration is recommending that all
Americans including the young and
healthy worked to engage in schooling
from home when possible avoid gathering
in groups of more than 10 people avoid
discretionary travel and avoid eating
and drinking in bars restaurants and
public food courts it's very good advice
the president also said for the first
time yesterday that this crisis could
lead to a recession on Wall Street
yesterday's you heard the stocks
plummeted right after the opening bell
the Dow Jones Industrials lost nearly
3,000 points that is close to 13 percent
the US has now more than the u.s. now
has more than 45-hundred reported
coronavirus cases but the actual total
could be much higher at least 90 people
have died our coverage of this new
normal in America begins with mullah
legi in New York City mola it's
remarkably quiet in this typically crazy
City
absolutely Anthony it is you know New
Yorkers here are waking up to new rules
and that new normal that you guys are
talking about and that's really defined
by empty streets deserted desolate
streets this is Columbus Circle
one of the busier areas in the city it
sits adjacent to Central Park but of
course as you mentioned bars restaurants
coffee shops all closed retail stores
have adjusted their hours as you can see
illustrated by that sign and further
illustrated by the transit systems here
Columbus Circle one of the busier subway
stations in the city normally hundreds
if not thousands of people would be
pouring out of here as you can see now
down to a trickle meanwhile in other
parts of the country leaders are taking
even more drastic measures
to stop the spread of the virus the
streets of New Orleans eerily quiet on
the eve of st. Patrick's Day the crowds
were kept home after Louisiana forced
all bars to close over coronavirus fears
from San Francisco to New York City
businesses were shuttered Monday night
and streets deserted under similar
orders
come by the way you look this is
something it's an invisible enemy
the president's guidance to limit
gatherings to no more than 10 people as
part of a plan for all Americans to help
stop the spread
something emphasized by the White House
coronavirus response coordinator on the
CBS Evening News with Norah O'Donnell if
you get behind a pandemic this virus is
about 2 to 3 times more contagious than
flu and so that's why we want everybody
to do everything that they can
New York New Jersey and Connecticut
announced a coordinated social life shut
down with theaters and gyms closed and
restaurants and bars limited to takeout
and delivery in the San Francisco Bay
Area officials called for several
counties to shelter in place what we are
asking for everyone to do is to remain
at home for all but the most essential
outings for your safety and the safety
of those around you the mass shut down
is being felt by businesses big and
small chef Eric repair of New York's
late Bernardin restaurant says he is not
able to pay his staff but is committed
to covering their health insurance
through April what are the discussions
that are being had while grocery stores
have been inundated some shops have set
aside special time just for seniors a
group that's especially vulnerable to
the virus we've been standing in line
for other markets but by time we get in
there's a lot of it gone
travelers are also on high alert this
Delta flight to Seattle was grounded in
New York Monday night after a passenger
said they might have been exposed to
coronavirus but the race for a vaccine
took a drastic step Monday when Jennifer
Haller from Seattle volunteered to
become the first person to receive an
experimental dose I know everybody feels
so helpless right now and I was so
excited to be given this opportunity to
actually do something tangible to
potentially help thousands millions of
people
Oh potential vaccine still being studied
but Tony we're still about a year away
from any sort of widespread use can't
come soon enough mola thank you very
much